この経典はトーデーヤプッタ・スバというあるバラモンとのお釈迦様との対話なんですね
そこで このトーデーヤプッタがお釈迦様にこの一つの質問を出します
で 在家の人に あの 善というか
あの 日本語であまりうまくならないんですけど
まあこのヤーヤン・ダンマン・クサランという
あの 善を獲得することというか
まあ善になることというか
この まあ道徳的な言葉で
この いわゆるこの人間として
まあ道徳的にまあ何を獲得するべきか
何を得るべきかという
まあその場合は英語でもまあGoodという言葉を使いますから
What is goodというね
で 善というものはまあ獲得すること
在家の人にできて 出家の人はできませんと
で クサラン・ダンマン
で まあまあ 善法という
まあ考え方がね なかなか大変難しいんですけど
まあ人間として生きている場合は
この道徳を語るときは
まあ倫理を語る場合は
まあどのように生きていって
まあ何を達するべきかと
という疑問が倫理の中で考えるんですね
人がどのように生きるべきか
その生きていて何に達するかという
で その時使う言葉なんですね
まあ善という言葉は で Right
とGoodという答えが二つありますね Right
and Wrong Good
という場合はEvilという反対の言葉 Right
の場合はWrongというになってきて
それはまあ倫理の話をするときはまあ使うものだそうですね
で こちらでもこの その意味では使ってます
まあ日本の倫理学でも
まあそれなりに適切な言葉を使っていると思います
で その善たるものっていう
善の道というかね それは歩めるのはまあ在家の人ですよと
出家はできませんという考え方がこのスバさんが持っているんですね
で スバはまあ 自分の考え方というよりも
まあ自分たちの考え方
このブラモン教の人々の考え方はまあそういう風に言ってるんです
それでお釈迦様の考え方は何なのかと
それはお釈迦様は まあこの場合はもう自分はやっぱりこのヴィバッジャワディー
物事を分析して分別して喋りましょうと
で お釈迦様はいつでもやっぱり分別論をとるんですね
で 一概に何々かというふうには言わない
よくよく分別して分けて分けて
それから判断するんですね
まとめて何かということはちょっと言えません
それでお釈迦様は言うのは
出家であろう在家であろうが
ミッチャーパティパッティン
間違った生き方はもう認めませんと
そこでバラモン人の考え方とブッダの倫理の考え方
倫理の考え方はそこら辺で変わっていくんですね
だから倫理というならば
正しい道と正しくない道があって
正しい道が歩むことは倫理であって
正しい道が歩まないことは倫理ではありませんというふうに言うべきところ
バラモン人はある社会の構造で出家か在家かと決めて
出家が正しい道を歩んでない
在家が正しい道を歩んでいるというふうに言ってるんですね
で その考え方は間違ってるっていうのはブッダの考え方なんですね
だからバラモン人はこの社会構造っていうのは大事にするんですよ
で 社会構造によって倫理的な価値のラベルを入れて入れていくんですね
で 例えばバラモン人が生まれた当時にも宗教家であって
宗教家形なんですね で
プリースト殿ですね だからこのプリーストに生まれたら
そのプリーストで誰々でという社会構造
で あれはまあ父親がバラモン人でプリーストであるならば
息子も当然バラモン人でプリーストである
娘もそうなるんだと 父親がすごい精神的な優れた人であるならば
必ず息子もそれからその立場を取ると
というのは この社会構造を大事にするっていうようなことで
それはこの日本の社会でもよく見えることで
この新興宗教とかね 作っている人々がいて
自分たちがすごいこのもう悟っているというか
ブッダになっているというか
神になっているというか
そうやって何か自分が真理を分かっているんだっていうことは
まあまず言ってるんですね
言って たくさん信者さんを作って
大変人気があって教えを広げています
それで その新興宗教の開祖という人が死んでしまったら
必ず娘か息子か次の開祖様になるんですね
ですから これ父親が修行での結果として得た精神的な優れている境地が必ずしも息子にもあるという論理なんです
ですから これはこの大変な
このいい加減な考え方ではなくて
日本でもものすごい今までしっかりとある考え方なんです
だからわかりやすいと思います
しかし その理屈は何なのかと私もちょっとわからないんですけど
私は仏教の人だから なんで父親が死んじゃったら
もうすぐに息子がその聖なる境地に堂々といるんでしょうかということはちょっとわからないんですけど
何か理屈はあるとは思います
だってそれはわかりません
で 社会構造はそのよく認めるっていうことは
バラモン人の間でも インド文化ってですね
インド文化でもよくしっかりとあったことで
例えばこの王家の人々がね
神に選ばれた神の特別な選ばれた存在だよと思ったら
その連中の親戚やらみんな大変尊い存在になるんですね
で 王室の人々とかね それも考え方次第で
王がそこら辺の誰かのジジイだと思っちゃうと
別にどうったことはない
例えばヨーロッパの国々ではね
王室はありますね あの
何でしたっけ ノーベル賞の国はまあスウェーデン
スウェデンにもまあ王がいるんですけど
そこら辺のジジイだと思ってるんです
みんな だから大したことはないんで
買い物にも行くし で 行ったらもう人がどうですか
元気ですか？と喋ったら
みんな喋ったりもするし
で あまり気にしない で
すごい一般人として生活する
しかし ちゃんとした法律的に王は王なんですけど
その状態はイギリスになってくるともうかなり違う
そう簡単に一般人とは交びるということはしません
だから 王という人がもう神やと思っちゃうと
やっぱりそちらの親戚どもたちがみんなもう神として考えて拝んだりする
で その人がどこかに座ったら
その場所は人はもうまた座りません
その人がどこかの部屋に寝ちゃ寝ると
それでまあ 四十年経ってもその部屋でその看板をかけて
何々さんががもう何とかしたところやとかね
で そういうふうなことをするっていうのは
まあ実際に世の中にあるんです
イギリスでも昔はかなりあって
まあどんどんやっぱりそれがまあ現代人があまり認めないんだから
自分たちもまあその塀を破って
一般人と一緒に行動した方がいいんではないかというね
それでイギリス女王の何年目でしたっけね
即位の 去年 ものすごい大騒ぎで記念式典やりましたからね
年もっとかな わからない
で かなりあの方も年ですからね
若く見えるんですけど
もうそこもね まあ四十五十ぐらいだからね
なんとかもう六十年のそこかなんとかやりました
すっごい大スケールで
イギリス人みんなもうそれ
その場合は初めてあのケントケンハム宮殿をね
まあオープンにして その中でみんな集めて
ロック音楽やったり 一般人が好きなものは全部やってしまったんですね
で エリザベスさんもみんなみんなと一緒に座って
何週間もかけて まあいろんな世界からね
みんな参加してくれましたし
だからまあこの一般人があまり気にしない場合は
そちらも王の王ではなくて
神の座から降りますが
で この現象ですね で これがもうヒンドゥー文化でもしっかりとあります
で 生まれによって 社会構造によって倫理が決けると
で とにかくもうどんな家で生まれたかっていうことで
道徳的な人間か 非道徳的な人間かっていうね
ことは 階級によって決めるものだと
だから神の人間がないかということは
王家に生まれたかないかということで決めちゃいますから
王家の血縁で生まれたら
もう神 一般の社会人に生まれたら
もう一般人で それで王が何か勲章やら何か名誉を与えたら
その人々は特別別な人間でとかね
それでまた一般人がその人に頭下げて
もう下げなくちゃいけない
だから人を敬うっていうことは
まあ一応そういうことで
階級制度で人を敬う 道徳で人を敬うっていうことはしない
というのは世界では一応一般的にある考え方で
まあお釈迦様はどうしておかしいことばっかし
みんな信じられない 認めないことばっかし言ってるんだから
お釈迦様はそれはあまり認めないんですね
お釈迦様は全く全く違った倫理を語るんですね
倫理といえば このミッチャーパティパダンというか
在家であろうが出家であろうが
いわゆる社会構造どうであろうか
生き方が正しいかないかっていうことで決めるんだよと
尊敬するべきかないか
善か悪かっていうことは
だからブッダの考え方
いまだに世の中であまり認めてないし
ほんのわずかな人々しか信じて信頼しませんだから
やっぱりまだまだ世の中はその倫理の場合はね
本当にどう考えてるかっていうことはよく私なんかはわからないんですよ
人の家柄によって道徳決めてしまうという
階級によってね 仏教ではやっぱりこの生き方で決めますよと
家と社会構造は全く関係ないというかね
ですから 出家であるこちらはもう在家出家にだけに分けてますね
なぜこちらでそういう風になったかというと
このスバさんがバラモン人で
だから宗教家なんですね
お釈迦様も宗教家なんですね
だからこの宗教家 プリースト同士で話してるんですよ
そこでプリースト同士で喋ってる場合は
一人のプリーストが在家で
一人のプリーストが出家ですよ
だから同じ土台が成り立ってるんですね
道徳を語る場合は 釈尊も聖職者で
しかし出家で スバさんも聖職者で
しかし在家で そこでバラモンたちのという聖職者たちの考え方は
在家は道徳的で善たる道を歩んでいる
出家にはできませんということで
もう出家を倫理的にダメだと言ってるんですね
そこで同じ土台で 両方とも聖職者でお釈迦様も同じ立場で答えを上げているんです
で それで聖職たがるバラモン人と聖職者であるお釈迦様を置いて
どちらが倫理的かというと
お釈迦様はこの場合は私は分別して喋りますよと
区別して喋りますよと
区別はどういうことかというと
出家であろうと在家であろうが
あの善たる道歩むならば
それが正しいんであって
間違っている生き方しているならば
それが全く自分が認めませんと
だから倫理っていうのは評価ですから
で その場合ははっきりと釈迦様は評価するという言葉を使うんですね
だから倫理学の場合はこのvalue judgementということで
まあ価値判断の世界なんですよ
ですから このどんな道がよろしいかと判断しなくちゃいけない
それでお釈迦様もこのワンネーミという言葉ははっきりと使います
私は褒めますと いわゆる評価しますと
在家の人の間違った生き方は褒めませんし
在家の人の正しい生き方を褒めますと
出家の人のも間違った生き方は褒めますし
褒めませんし 出家の正しい生き方を褒めますということで
そこで なんで在家が善たる道を歩むかというところで
バラモン人の考え方を次にお釈迦様に言うんですね
その場合も誤解してほしくないのは
これはまあ 聖職者二人間の倫理に対する対話ですからね
そこで在家の聖職者いて
出家の聖職者いると 両方聖職者で
それで在家の聖職者にとっては大変仕事はあります
在家だから あらゆることをしなくちゃいけない
同じ聖職者たる出家は何もやることはない
ですから 仕事多い 苦労多い在家聖職者をまあどう見たっても立派ではないかと
仕事をしながら 家族の面倒を見ながら
もう社会のいろんなことに手を出しながら
あらゆることをやりながら
お経をあげたりするんだよと
で まあブラマン人は一応お経をあげるぐらいの宗教でしたからね
お葬式に行ってお経上げてくるわ
結婚式に行ってお経上げてくるわということはやってるんですね
だから大変忙しいんではないかと
バラモン人は一般人に向かってやっていた宗教活動っていうのは
まあ仏教でやってるこのお経あげることです
で 子供が生まれたら結婚式
そういうものと そうやって人々の幸福
不幸な出来事の時は まあ必ず結婚式はまあやりますね
まあその時まあ しかし
在家の人だから いろんな人の結婚式にね
走り回るということはね
そう簡単な仕事ではありません
で この人はいろんな結婚式に行かなくちゃいけないんだから
普通の在家の人っていうのは
自分の親戚の結婚式以外は行きませんだから
でも聖職者はそうではなくて
自分の管轄のすべての在家の人々の結婚式に走り回らなくちゃいけない
しかし その人と一緒に自分も田んぼを作っているんですよ
[背景音楽]そうするとどうなるかというと
やっぱり田んぼをみんなと一緒に作らなくちゃいけないし
で 田んぼでじゃあ今日は種まく日だよと決めたところで
結婚式が入り込んじゃうと
そちらに行かなくちゃいけない
とにかくこのバラモン人たちはもうなんとか全部やってるんです
それにしてみれば 出家っていうのはもう全然社会生活ないんだから
田んぼの仕事やらね もう全然ないんですね
だから出家もいろいろ人々の修復したり
なんとかしていたっても
全然苦労も何もないんです
毎日結婚式があったっても全然問題ないんだから
他別にやることはないんだからね
毎日各地の結婚式のところに訪ねて
修復して起き上げて帰ることはできるんです
バラモン人がそれをやると
もう大変な苦労をしているということで
そういうところから考えれば
やっぱり立派なのは在家
生殖者ですよっていうことになるんですね
そのポイント持ってきたっても
お釈迦様はやっぱり私は分別論で語ってますよと
で そちらでは結果論 この倫理語る場合はもう結果論で見る
原因論で見るという二つ
大雑把に二つあります
で いろんなことをね やってはいけないと
まあ皆様はインドの倫理学を習らなくたってもね
西洋の倫理には大変詳しいと思いますけど
で まあ私は全然ホームテキストも読んでないんです
ですからあまりわかりません
しかし 例えば嘘を言ってはいけないんだぞという場合は
嘘を言って社会に迷惑をかけられる場合は
まあそれはもう結果論で良くないという
あるいはもう神がそんなことを禁止しているんだよというところで
神に逆らっている 故に間違っているという倫理もあります
で 聖書に あるいは神の言葉に禁止しているものはもう禁止だと
で 例えばよくない行為などなどは西洋で良くないと思っているのは
まあただ神がやってはいけないという重罪に入りますよと
それで別に神は気にしなくてもいいということになると
もう思い存分やってもいいということで
今はもう遊びたい放題遊んでいること自体が倫理になっているんですね
特に西洋の場合は この神の言葉というか
聖書ということはもうすごい決まり手になっている
すごい土台になってます
まあインド人にとってはやっぱりそれなりのヴェーダ聖典とかだったり
我々にとってはブッダの言葉があって
そこはもう倫理決める基本手本になってしまうんですね
そこで倫理学者が問題にするのは
そうやってあるテキストを手本にして倫理っていうのは決められますか？という疑問をまた出したりするし
で こちらでは次に出てくるのはこの結果で考えるということなんですね
結果で考える 良い ただたくさん良い結果出すものはあの善の道で
結果が少ない場合はこの道である
もうあまり評価できませんと
ということで 在家は大変な仕事をしているんだから
彼らの行為が結果大きいんだと
出家はそんな仕事をしてないんだから
まあ結果が少ないということで
故に真理の倫理の道は在家が歩んでいると
そういう場合でも お釈迦さんは私は分別していますよと
在家の仕事にしても 仕事多い
苦労多い仕事もあるし
苦労少ない仕事もあるんじゃないかと
苦労多い仕事にしたってうまくいけばもうたくさん結果があるし
うまくいかなかったら結果は全くないし
苦労少ない商売みたいな仕事にしても
うまくいけばたくさん儲かっちゃうし
うまくいかなかったら全く損してしまうし
ですから ただ苦労多い苦労少ないだけで
どちらかっていうことは決められることはできませんと
それでこの倫理の世界で
その人は次のポイントに移ってみるんですね
で まあじわじわと負けてしまいますが
第一のスタンスを出してみたんですね
社会構造でも決定的に倫理決まってるんだと
どんな階級の人 どんな家柄の人が善で
どんな家の人が悪でっていうことで
生まれで決まってるんだよという世界一般的に認めている考え方
この世界で一般的に認められる考え方から
聖職者にだけの世界に入って
そこでまた一つ 次に結果論で出してみるんですね
で 結果論で出す場合は
結果論という結果は出してないんで
この人は この人はただ苦労多いか苦労少ないかっていうところで
方法論ですね 方法論で結果決めると
だから苦労多い在家の仕事は結果が大きいんだと
苦労少ない出家の生き方は結果が少ないと
苦労多いかないかっていうことで
まあやっぱり方法論で決めてしまっちゃう
それでお釈迦様が方法論ではなくて
本当に結果が多いか少ないかというところで結果から反論するんですね
結果から反論すると 在家の人は苦労多くても成功する場合もあるし
成功しない場合もあるし
在家の道でも苦労少ない仕事もあるんじゃないかと
その場合も成功する場合もあるし
成功しない場合もある
ですから 苦労多いかないかではなくて
成功しているかないか
結果が多いかないかと
そこら辺で道が決めるんではないかと
ところで それもまあ断ってしまいますね
次にこの道徳を決める場合は
倫理学で使う次のポイントというのは
心の状況という人の気持ちということなんですね
いわゆる西洋の言葉ではコンシャスという言葉がありましてね
このコンシャスとは何なのかと
って何でしたっけ？良心ですね
で 心の状態 良心というものがあるんではないかと
ということで 良心に合うものは正しくて
良心に合わないものは正しくないとは言うのは簡単ですが
倫理学者はそう簡単にはうまくいかないんですね
良心って何なのかと あるんですかと
そんなのは人間にと それが倫理学で考えなくちゃいけないことなんですね
一般人がまあ良心に逆らうんだから
やっぱり悪いやと 自分の良心に合ってるんだからいいことやっていうのはもうずいぶん大ざっぱで決めますけど
そんなことはできません
本当に良心というものあるかないか
また決めなくちゃいかない
こちら次にこの良心の世界に入って
この心の状態に入って
バラモンたちは 5つのことを育てるように言ってるんだよと
5つのことなんですかというと
サッチャン 1番目 サッチャンというのは事実真理
本当のこと 偽りでないことですね
それからタパン修行すること
自分頑張る 努力すること
修行すること タパンですね
それからアッジェーナン
アッジェーナンというのはまああれでしょ
勉強することです 習うこと
特に宗教の世界では あらゆる経典をしきたり
いろんなことを習わなくちゃいけないんですね
あらゆること 勉強すること
それを 3番目で  4番目は 5
番目  4番目なんですか？アッジェーナン 4番目
サッチャンとタパン ディティアン
あ ブラフマチャリアン
ブラフマチャリア 3番目
奉行 道徳的な生き方 ブラフマチャリアにはいろいろ一応いろいろ意味が
梵行と言うんですが 一応若い時は全く性的な欲をもう抑えなくちゃいけない
全く何もしてはいけないと厳しいんですね
それでブラマン人は結婚しますが
結婚したらまあまた欲しがらない行為やらいろんなことは全くしないで
ちゃんと家族を守っていることも
それもブラフマチャリーに入るんですよ
で 自分が子供を作ったり
いろいろなことをしたりするんですけど
不倫をしたり浮気をしたりっていうのは
これはやめて家族を守る
それから子供が大きくなってくると
自分もそれなりに年取っていくし
それでまた欲を足すと突然
で 必要な子供を作って終わったところで
もういいっていうことで頑張って欲を足す
足す そこからまたブラフマチャリー
だからブラフマチャリーにはセットができているんですよ
初めはこのもうまだまだ子供で若者で
もうだからまあそのふざけたり遊んだり
そういうことをしては絶対ダメですよということで身を守る
それでちゃんと大人になってからは結婚する
結婚したらまた不倫したりやいろいろなことはしないで
家族を守ることで欲をコントロールする
それで必要な子供ができて大きくなってくる
もう子供大きいなと分かったところで
またもう踏ん張ってそこで欲を足すという３段階があるんですね
ブラフマチャリーには
それが大変道徳的な努力生き方であるということで
これ 3番目  4番目は勉強することで経典を上げたり
呪文を唱えたりすることで
5番目はチャーガン まあ布施ですね
で いわゆるものに執着しない
すべて捨てるということなんです
それで バラモン人の生き方から見れば
年取ると全財産捨てましょう
みんなではなくて捨てましょうという理想的な生き方があるんです
自分が一応若い時 中年までは一生懸命仕事をして儲かりたい
お金儲けて大金持ちになる
大金持ちになって 子供たちに勉強させてあげて
家を建ててあげたりとかね
いろいろなことはする
して 子供たちが一人前になった途端
自分が全ての財産を捨てる
捨てて道に入る 出て行く
それから何も持ってない
もう貧乏 今まで儲かったもうお金やら商売したならば
そういうものやら全部きれいさっぱりやめる
やめるだけじゃなくて
やめて家でご飯食べて
もう犬の散歩しながら寝ているかという
そういうこともしない
家からもう出て行く 出て行ってホームレスの生活になるんですね
それからあちこち物を買うて食べ物ぐらいは買うて食べたりします
それがチャーガなんですよ
与える 布施するということで
これなかなか大変なことで
もう大変立派な行為でね
そう簡単にできるわけじゃないんですよ
ものすごく豊かな贅沢で
また自分で苦労して儲かった財産もあるでしょうしね
親からもらったものもあるかもしれませんだけど
親から頂いた財産 それをまた反映されて
自分でいろいろ仕事して
もう大金持ちになったところで
全部捨てて もうホームレスになるという
これ大変なことですよ
だから 誰かさんが私に言ってるような
ただホームレスこそ悟っているんだよというね
やっぱりそれは日本の道徳倫理観で
我々外人にとってはなんか全然さっぱりわからない
私には電子メールでね
あんたはすごくとんでもない人間やと
で 本当の聖者っていうのはもうホームレスだとというふうなことでガチャガチャ書いてありましたけどね
で 私はわからないんだからね
返事出したらきついし
黙っていたんです だからまあただ女遊びをして賭け事をしてね
ホームレスになっただけで
なんか道徳あるわけじゃなくて
やっぱり世捨て人なんですよ
それがもう大変なことでね
で このブラマン人の場合はそういうことをしましょうという風に
この道徳のセットができているんですね
だからだからといってみんなやるということは
またそこはおかしいんですよ
で 誰かさんがタイに行ったら誰かタイ人に騙されたと
だから仏教とはてなんですかと
というふうな考え方っていうのは
私たちから見れば あなたに脳細胞 1個ぐらいでもあるかというふうに聞きたくなるんですよ
すべての人間 一斉に一つのことをするんですかね
この世の中で 平気で自分たちもやってないのに
他人にそれを期待するという
例えば仏教は厳密な戒律やら嘘を言ってはいけない
人を騙してはいけないとか
云々と欲はあってはならんとかね
修行しなくちゃあかんぞとか
涅槃を体験しない これ言ってるは言ってることは言ってますから
一斉に仏教徒であるならばみんな悟ってるんだぞと思うことって何なのかと
同じことを私たちにもそうすると言いたくなりますよ
外国ではもう日本人というのはすごく道徳が正しく
謙虚で正直で 人信頼できる人間やと
みんなそうですかね 賄賂取る人は一人もいないんです
この世の中で 玄関には別に鍵かける必要ない
みんなもうすごい道徳的で倫理的で正しいんだからね
セキュリティなんか全然いらん
だからまあ 日本の家にセキュリティ入ってるんだからといって
日本人にみんな泥棒ですよって言えるんです逆に
なんでそんなことを言うかっていうことはね
私にはちょっと理解できないんですよ
例えば日本ではいろんな家に見たらもうセキュリティつけてるんですよ
故に日本人みんな驚くですよ
というのはどういう思考ですかね
だからまあ仏教では云々と言ってはいますけど
それは実行するかしないかっていうようなことは別な話で
バラモン人にしても もうテキストではバラモン
理想的なバラモン人の生き方はこういう生き方であるんであって
それを実行するかしないかということは
そのそのバラモン人が勝手にやってるでしょうに
お釈迦様に会った このものすごい 80歳ぐらいの年取ったバラモン人たちがいて
ものすごい学者で有名で
みんなそれでも大勢の弟子たちと一緒にもう大金持ちでいたんですよ
ジャーヌソーニとかかなり有名で
アッサラーヤナとかね
すっごい大金持ちで またもうもう王様ほどもう人気と尊敬あった人々なんですね
で セーラというバラモンというのは
あまりにも立派なバラモン人で
自分でブッダに会っては良いか無いかということは
弟子たちをまず先に入れて調べなさいよと
私のような人が行って会ってもよろしい
そういう道徳 知識ある人ですかと
それぐらい自分の立場があるんですよ
セーラさんがいて 誰か誰かと話しましたと言ったら
その人の立場がぎゅっともう人気が出てきて上がってしまうんですよ
あのセーラバラモン人も自分で行って挨拶に行って喋りましたよということで
だからセーラさんが だから自分が行く前に下調べをさせるんですよ
そのバラモン人はよほどの人間ではなかったんです
ではセーラさんが知らなかったんですかね
自分の経典でそんなことを書いているんだということは
それは当然知っているんでしょう
いや 知ってるところがその人教えてるんだから
弟子たちに だからどんな道を選ぶかっていうことは
そのその人の問題であって
親が子供 3人作ったら一人が泥棒になったって
それを親がそのお前大きくなったら泥棒になりなさい
お前大きくなったら音楽家になれと言ってるわけじゃないでしょうに
ですから このまあ そういう考え方っていうのはね
ではまあちょっと理解
ちょっと難しくなっちゃうんですね
で そういうそんな考え方だったら
やっぱりまあ同じ土台では喋れないっていうことになってしまうんですよ
ですから この 5つのポイントの場合でも
それはもう道徳的な人間は何なのかというバラモン人の考え方
サッチャンタパンブラフマチャリアンね
まあサッチャタパブラフマチャリア
アジェサナンチャガ サッチャタパブラフマチャリアアジェサナンチャガ
5つも立派な考え方なんですね
どう考えても サッチャっていうのは
やっぱり事実 真理 本当のことを求めることなんですね
で そこが西洋では倫理に入ってないんですよ
あの智慧を探し求めることは倫理として見てないんです
で インド文化ではやっぱり智慧を探し求めること
真理を探し求めること
事実は何なのか 本当のことは何なのかと
いわゆるあの智慧を智慧を探し求めること自体も倫理なんですね
そのポイントでは 西洋とは随分違うんですね
西洋ではこの事実真理を探すことが倫理と全く関係ない
もう別な世界 これはエピステモロジーの世界で
で あるいは形而上学ですか
メタフィジックスとかね
なんとかの世界で で エティクスの場合はもう善と悪の判断だけの生き方だけのことです
で エピステモロジー メタフィジックス
エティクスとか そういう風にこの哲学思考はもう明確に分けることはインド文化では無理です
全部ワンセットで だから道徳も全部一つにワンセットになっているんです
だからこのサッチャン真理何なのかと事実を探し求める
これは大変な立派なことで
この生き方 いろんなことを試したりして
いろんなことを調べたりして
本当のことって何なの？例えば人間にチャクラはもう 7つあるぞと言ったら
ああそうですか 信じましょうって
それはないんです やってみて本当かないかとかね
で やってみる それがまあ真理を探す方法であって
やってみて まあ事実であるならば事実だと
嘘だったらこれは嘘よ
真実ではありませんと
では私はそれからまたさらに真理を探すぞということで
また出かけるというのは普通のサッチャの生き方で
だから 1つ一つにたっても
本当に立派な項目 5つなんですね
それでお釈迦様がどうしてもこのバラモン人と一緒に賛成はしたくないんですね
もうとにかく潰しちゃうというかね
今までの 3つの立場でもうブラマン
このスバさんがもうもう粉々に潰れてしまっちゃったんで
お釈迦様の反論で そこでまあこれだったら勝つぞという
この 5つのポイントを出しちゃうんですね
これだったら たとえ釈尊にも反論できんぞと
いわゆる心の状態というか
心の育ち方についてどうですかと
それ育ち方だったら 我々は 5つ
人間の道として 聖職者の道として語っているんだよと
でお釈迦様はそれで聞くのは
君の先生はそれちゃんと知ってましたと
一人でもバラモン人がいますかと
それはちゃんと自分で経験して
体験して発見する いわゆる法則を通して
科学的な研究をして何か発見するでしょう
そんな感じで法則を通して発見した
まあ一応推測としては分かりますけど
例えばあの生姜とかなんとか飲めば風邪にはよろしいやと
まあそれはまあ感覚として
あの別に誰も反対しません
しかし 風邪はこういうこういう原因で引きますよと
生姜にはこういう成分がありまして
これとこれが合うとビグッと風邪ウイルスが壊せますよというふうなことが一番大事なポイントなんですよ
科学ではそういうことなんですね
ただ 焼いたネギを首にかけたら風邪が引きませんよというふうにそうは思わないのが科学者なんですね
だからこの実際に真理を発見してから言うべきであると
それで生姜の成分 にんにくの成分
あるいは何でもいいんだから
成分をちゃんと分析して
それと稼ぎたら体に起こるいろんな問題もちゃんと見て
それだったらこれ それだったらこれこれと医者が言う場合は
もう何の問題もなくみんなにそれを使うことはできますよ
ですから やたらに言うなよと
一般人っていうのはもうやたらに言うんですよ
いろんなこと ちょっとお腹の調子が悪いったら
まあではこれ飲みなさいと
それもう真剣に飲んであげたら
もう一人がではこれ飲みなさいと
それで死にますよ もうお腹がもうとっくにもう調子が悪いんだから
何も飲まん方がいいんですけど
で くるくる人が自分好き勝手で
無責任であれやこれやと言う
それはあまり真理の人はやることではありません
で 病気になったらちゃんと治療を受けて
ちゃんと薬やって それだけ使っちゃえば
それで病気あるならば
それ治してしまいますね
あれやこれやとね うちのおばあさんがこんなことをやってました
その時はとかね もう一人が私のおじいさんがこんなことやったって
やられる側がどうなるんですかねと
だからこのそういう立場では決めませんというのは仏教の立場なんですね
あなたのおばあさんが何やったっても
あなたのおじいさんが何やっても
これ関係ないんだと 逆にあなたのおばあさんが本当に知っていたんですかと
この病気にこれだということは発見していたんですかと
言うならば 私のおばあさんがもう医学博士で
もうウィーンからこういうこういう賞も取って
まあこういうこういう人で
これと言ったらもう問題ないでしょうね
それだったらあなたのおじいさん言うことではなくて
このおばあさん言うこと聞きますよということははっきり決められるでしょうに
そういうそのポイントでこちら出しているのは
一人のバラモンでも これがちゃんと発見して真理であること
これが法則としてファクト
事実 真理ですと このイッスッスは
そういう風に研究して発見した人がいますかということで
それは修行の世界だから研究して発見するんじゃなくて
サヤン・アヴィンニャン・サッチカと自分で経験して体験していますかと
それでバラモン人はそうおっしゃると一人もいませんよと
では 先生の先生でも一人がいるんですかと
先生の先生の一人もいませんと
それで逆にではヴェーダ・セータン・スッタ
アッタカ・ヴァーマカ・デーヴァカ・ナン・オムモンタユ・シッチニンナ・センニン・タチェカ
アッタカ・ヴァーマカ・ヴァーマデーヴァ・ウェッサーミタ・ヤマ・タッキ・アンギーラサ・バラッドワージャ・ワーセットカッサ・バブ
六人ですね 自分たちでこのイッスッスが心を回転させる
心を成長させる 心を 禅の道に導かれる原因はこの五つですよと
はっきりと発見していますかといえば
発見していたならば言ってますからね
発表しますからね 論文は
それはないと そうするとお釈迦様はだから若者よ
お前も知らないし お前の先生も知らないし
先生の先生も知らないし
七代目まで聞いたっていうのもそいつらも知らないし
もう結局は最初にヴェーダ聖典を作った先人たちも知らないでしょうに
これはもう初めの人にも目が見えないし
今の人も目から目が見えない人々の輪なんですね
アンダヴェーヌ アンダヴェーヌっていうのは
このヴェーヌっていうのはあの竹ですよ
それでまあ竹は末に使うんだから
もうこれはアンダヴェーヌ・パランパラ
みんな前の人の末をつかま握ってはいます
しかし自分に目が見えないんだから
前に歩く歩く人の末をつかまっています
握ってます それで同じ
みんなみんな先生の話を聞いて
先生の先生の話を聞いていて
結局一人も目が見えないんだったら
君たちはどこに行くんですかということなんです
そこでアンダヴェーヌ・パランパラ
目が見えない人の末のパランパラ
伝統 目が見えない人の伝統ではないかと
ということで この伝統という言葉をわざと使うんです
だから言葉を選ぶ時はもうものすごい厳密にお釈迦様が決めるんですよ
なぜこのパランパラという言葉を使いますかというと
ブラマン人が自分の宗教は正しいというために権威として出す一つはこの切れてない伝統なんですよ
それは一つインドの普通一般的な考え方で
例えばテーラワーダ仏教もその時点ではものすごい厳しいんですよ
お釈迦様から伝統は切れては絶対いけませんと
伝統を切れちゃうと認めません
それからは だからそれは特に出家の場合は
教えの場合はそれほど厳しくないんだけど
で 出家の伝統だから お釈迦様が最初の弟子たちを作って
その弟子たちが次の弟子たちを作って
そこでサーリプッタ モクレン両尊者がサンガの一番上で
そこからどんどん来て
お釈迦様亡くなったらマハーカッサパ尊者がいて
それからどんどんどんどん伝統は一つ一つずっとチェックして
それでアショーカ帝王の時代でマヒンダさんというね
息子がスリランカに行って
彼も五人のお坊さんと一緒に来て
五人でないと出家できませんから
それでずっともう伝統をつなげて
そこで大寺派っていうものができて
それで大寺派からテーラワーダ仏教はいろんな国々に広げていってるという
伝統切れちゃうともうダメですね
そこで 例えば社会的な問題があってお坊さんってみんな殺されたりします
政府に それでお坊さんが亡くなる
法がありますけど そうするともう伝統切れちゃったんだから
また輸入するんですね
自分たちがあっちこっち種植えてるんだから
その考えて だからタイやらミャンマーやらいろんなところでちゃんと
そうするとタイから輸入するか
ミャンマーから輸入するか
その場合は伝統切れたことにならないんですね
同じ伝統だから しかし
中国からは輸入しません
中国のお坊さんが呼んで仏教を復活しようとは絶対しません
そちら伝統ないんだから
だからこのテーラワーダの場合は
権威と言えば もうこれを伝統ずっと一本でつなげているということで
その同じ決まりで同じ仕来りで
次の人 新しい人を出家させて
同じ伝統を同じことを教えてあげる
その人も同じ仕来り同じ決まりで次の弟子を育て上げたりする
その風に時代交代をしているんですね
だから一人が自分で髪の毛を剃って
自分で衣を店で買ってきても
全くも認めません 全くもうどう踏ん張ってももう立ち入りできません
入れてくれません 追い出します
だからテーラワーダの場合
出家の場合はみんなに私は何々先生の先生であって
これこれでこれこういう人やってちゃんとないと
それから現代人っていうのは
特に仏教でない人々がね
タイ ミャンマーに行って出家します
その場合はちゃんと伝統的に出家はしますけどね
そこで好き勝手であちこち行ったり
自分一人で行動したりする
あれ認めないんですよ
認めないで 向こうはいくらかもう関係をもう義に入れておくんです
それで本人が何のことなく後ろに落ちてしまいます
ほとんどやがて原則ついてしまいます
伝統から外れちゃうと
もうそう長生きすることもできません
うん だからだからこれインド文化で
例えば現代人的に考えれば
人が勝手に衣を着て何が悪いんですかと
ただ これはただ一つ服ではないかと
だったら服ですよと あなたにとっては
でも出家ではありませんと
だからただ髪の毛剃っただけで
それはただ何か人は髪の毛を剃ったりもするし
伸ばしたりもするし 赤く染めたりもするし
パンチパーマすることもあるし
それぞれ自由ですよと
それとこちら関係ないんだと
だから出家の髪の毛剃るっていうことは
また別な儀式というかね
これ別なことなんです
で それにはそれなりの式でやるんです
では髪の毛を剃るそうと
ということで 長老たちの教会で髪の毛を剃るという行為を行うんですよ
それから自分で一人で髪の毛を剃ってもよろしいしね
だから一人一人そうやって昔からもう切れないように伝統を守っていく
ですから 伝統ということは
インド文化ではこの正しいということを言うために
一つのポイントというか
証拠になるものなんですね
だからテキストにしたって
私は一人で読んでみましたよと
ああそうですかと それ以上はいかないんですよ
私はこのテキストはこの学校で
この先生のところで読みましたと言っちゃうと
ああそうですかということで
もうその人は何者かがそこでわかるんですよ
だから学派がだから成り立つのですよ
同じヴェーダ聖典にしたって
ウパニシャッドにしたっても
そのその先生たちが自分たちの伝統の解釈を教えてあげる
だから解釈たくさんあります
で それが仏教にも影響は当然インドの影響を受けるのは受けるのは避けられない
仏教もインドのものだから
影響を受けるにも受けないにも関係ないんですよ
インドのものですから
それでブッダの教えにしたっても
学説は成り立ちますよ
しかし 分かれたとこはもうとんでもないアホなことなんですね
だからこの経典は あのお坊さんはこういう風に解釈する
あのお坊さんはこういう風に解釈すると
それで私はそのお坊さんの弟子だから弟子ですよと言ったら
ではあなたはこの経典
こういう風に解釈するでしょうということになるだけであって
それでお釈迦様はそれを知っていて
先生の解釈っていうのは当てにするなよとはっきり言ってるんですね
たとえ偉大なる先生が
この経典はこういうブッダの本物
真の教えだと言っても
認めるなよと ちゃんと自分で経典に照らし合わせてみなさいと
だからそこはお釈迦様はちゃんと注意したのは
インドではそんなのはごく普通
当たり前 ウパニシャッドテキストにしたっても
解釈っていうのはもういくつかたくさんあります
学説 学派がそれぞれ たとえ日本の曹洞宗にしたっても
相貌現象の解釈っていうのはいくつかありますからね
学派が それで禅宗の方々が
は一番間違ってるテキスト
正しいものと認めているし
一番くだらない解説が本がありまして
いわゆる注釈ですよ その注釈は大変尊いと言っているんですけどね
それは私個人の考え方で
別にだからそうということじゃないんですよ
学問っていうのはそんなもんなんです
だから日本にある正法言宗にしたっても
注釈伝統はいくつかあるんですよ
だから同じ言葉の解釈っていうのはまるっきりぴったし同じわけじゃないんです
なんでいくつかあるかというと
やっぱりあなた間違ってるっていうことも言えないし
これが完全に正しい これはちょっと言いにくいし
とにかく両方ありがたいんだから
ということになるんですよ
そういう風にこの学問の場合でも学派が出たりするし
ですから伝統ということが大変大事になるんです
しかし 一般日本語の伝統という意味でもないんです
ただやってるんだからやるぞっていうことでもないんですけど
やっぱりすごく大事に大事に
次の次の次の世代に世代交代をさせてあげる
その伝統の中で当然開発は起こります
だから伝統っていうのは昔やったことはもうただそのまんまやるっていう意味でもないんです
なんでやるか 先生わかりません
昔からのしきたりやということは
あまり正しい伝統じゃないんです
だから伝統は生きてないと意味がないんですよ
だから受け継いで それを自分がちゃんと生かして
伝統をまわりながら次の世代に与えると
ですから 開発はありえます
伝統の中でも開発はあるんだけど
まるっきり伝統から外れるっていうことはもう決して認めることにはしないし
外れることも不可能であるし
外れたらその人がそれで消えてしまうんです
自動的に そういうことだから
この伝統ということが一つ大事なポイントなんです
これをお釈迦様は認めませんね
結局は 伝統だから何という事実でない場合は
だから ブラマン人にとってはもうポイントはこの 10人のヴェーダ聖典を作った前任さえも発見してないんではないかと
事実かないかは この 1つつのポイント
と言ったところで 我々は伝統ということが当然言うでしょうに
大事に守ってくる教えだよと
というとこは出すんだから
お釈迦さんはあなた方は目が見えない人々の伝統ですよと
全く判断何もできん人々の伝統ですよということで
伝統っていうことを使うんです
だからそれは直接バカにすることで
直接攻撃することでプライドを傷つけることなんですね
スバさんの だからこれ目が見えない人々の伝統ですねと言ったところで
もう自分の宗教そのものを侮辱されちゃっちゃうんですよ
だからアンダウェイにパランパラという言葉は
もうパーリ語で日本訳で見たら別になんのことないでしょ
その通りやって そうじゃないんです
あの人々にとっては決して言ってはいけない言葉なんですよ
一番尊いと思っている習慣ですよ
例えばテーラワーダでも同じですよ
ちょっと試しに言ってみてください
あなた方の伝統ってね
まあそんな綺麗とは思わないんですよとかね
どうなるかわからないんですよ
で 厳しく攻撃しますよ
それでテーラワーダの人の攻撃っていうのは気をつけた方がいいんです
で 生半可じゃないんです
この言葉は簡単に使えない
このアンダラパランという言葉
日常生活で使ったってもね
そんなに笑って済みますけど
ブラミン人に使っちゃうと
そのブラマン教そのものを否定することになるんです
例えばキリスト教の方々と聖書についていろんな異論を話し合うことはいくらでもできます
私がこれこう思いますよと言ったら
みんな西洋人で自由思想の人々だから
ああそうですか それ面白い考え方ですよ
しかし 私はこういう風に考えてますよとか
ものすごく仲良くいろんな異論を話し合うことができますよ
しかし あんた神を信じてる人でしょ？と
もう相手にならないと言ったら
それはそれでもう捨てられたんだから
これは侮辱ですよ それからはもう話合いになりませんね
もう根本的に元からも否定しちゃうと
だからスリランカで我々に学生と来てくれるのは
例えば外国やらヨーロッパやら
そういう人々にしゃべることになったならば
まず仏教は神を認めてないということは言わないでください
エティストということだけは使ってはいけませんと
それ言った途端 それで全面的に西洋文化
西洋人の生き方はもう否定したことになります
それを否定してどうやって教えるかと
だからずっとテーラワーダ仏教はそのエティストという言葉は使わないということにすごく気をつける
使わないでしゃべる 長い間しゃべったところで
神っていうのは成り立たないんだよと
しかし この人々はしっかりした道徳を語っているんだよと
だからエティスト無神論者と言った途端
道徳を否定するという意味なんですね
何の道徳もない もうなんていうのも
犯罪者というかね まあ乱暴そのものという意味で理解しちゃうんですね
自称の意味で理解するわけじゃないんですよ
神を信じない人にはエティスト言うんだよって
それは自称の意味で 実際はそういう意味と違う意味で使ってますね
そこでお釈迦様この言葉を言っちゃうんで
これでページの最後の段落
エヴ
ァンウッテスボーマーノトーデヤプットーバガヴァタアンダベーノプレメーナブッチャマーノクピトーアナッタマノーバガワンタンエーワクンセントーバガワンタンエーワ
ワンベントーバガワンタンエーワワダマーノサマノーゴータモーパーピコーバヴィッサティーティーバガワンタンエータドオーチャブラームノーボーゴータマポッカラサーティ・オパマニョーサブガワニコーエーワマーハ
そこでまあそれほど難しいところではない
日本語でどうなってますかね
これ 碁を振ってるところ
このように言われると
道提の子であるスベ青年バラモンは世尊から目の見えないものの列
だからまあ列というのは本当は伝統という
パランパラということなんですね
だから 列よりは意味を取る場合は
やっぱり伝統なんですよ
目の見えないものの伝統に例えて言われたことに怒り喜ばす
世尊のみを非難し 世尊のみを誹謗し
世尊のみにシャモンゴータマは悪くなるであろうと言いながら世尊にこう言った
全然日本語はわからないね
私は で バガワンタンゲーはクンセント
とにかくお釈迦様にも怒鳴ったんですね
バガワンタンゲーはワンベンと
もうお釈迦様をなんて言いますか
誹謗するんですね サマノーゴータマ・パーピコー・バヴィッサティ
釈尊が悪人だよ 何のことよ
あんたはもう悪人だよというんです
その意味ですよ こちらいるのはシャモンゴートは悪くなるであろうというのは
えーと パーピトバビッサティ
知らないこと まあ一応まあわかる人々は一応言葉を打ってみてください
このページのダンサンバムの段落で
エヴァンウッテスボマーノ
このように言われた時は
スバサンガ・バガヴァタ・アンダウェープ・アンダヴェーヌーパメーナ・ウッチャマーナ
釈尊に あの 目の見えない人々の伝統だと言われて
クピと怒って アナッタマンの機嫌が悪くなって
バガヴァンタンへ分先と釈尊を非難して
バガヴァンタンへワンベンと釈尊を侮辱というか
あの誹謗して バガヴァンタンへワダマン釈尊に言っちゃいますと
こんなこと だからこの誹謗誹謗しましたとかね
非難しましたと言ったっても
長い時間かけてガチャガチャガチャガチャ怒って喋ったわけじゃないんです
気持ち書いてるんです
お釈迦様は侮辱してやるぞと
お釈迦様は今返しやりますということなんです
私は徹底的に侮辱されちゃったんだから
ではお釈迦様も返してやりますということで
釈尊がもう悪人だと 全くもせんも道徳もない悪人だと釈尊に言うんですよ
サマナウゴートもパピコバビッサティ
で まあ私の訳ではこのこちらで
この あの 脚注でに打ってるところなんですけど
あのでパーピトバビッサティと取ってますけど
やっぱりパピコバビッサティっていうのは
あのテキストにあることで
これパーピタになったのかどうかわかりません
パーピタの意味は知らないこと
アジャーナナバハっていうのは注釈書の言葉だと思いますけど
一切智者でないこと アサッバンニューバハになるであろう
ということは注釈書でしょうね
まあそれはちょっとピンとは忘れてますから
そんな注釈書を見る必要もない
パーピタっていうのはもう悪人やという意味なんですよ
でも悪人って言ったっても
軽々しい悪人という意味じゃないんです
ものすごくちょっと意味が重い
なんか何かないんですか？それなりの
それなりの言葉 極悪人ですね
そうですね 釈尊こそ極悪人だよという風な
もうものすごくもう否定して捨てる言葉なんです
それにつけて彼がまたもう引用するんですね
バガヴァンタン さらにお釈迦様に言うんです
この若者はもうこの時間かけて
もうこの野郎とか何とか言ったわけじゃないんですよ
もう聖職者二人の間の話で
すごく丁寧で もう品格よく話し合っていたんですよ
で お釈迦様も何のことなく
やっぱりあの目の見えない人の伝統ですねということで
何のことなく極悪人のお釈迦様だよというだけのことなんです
言葉としては で 釈尊が極悪人であると
機嫌が悪くなってますよ
でお釈迦さんに向かって極悪人だって言ったら
これはもうやっぱりお釈迦様も誹謗することになるんですからね
で なんでそんなことを言いますかということをまたちゃんと説明しますよ
だからスバさんがまあいくら何でも立派な人格がある人
それは確かなんですよ
すごい人格で もう全く真っ向から対立してディスカッションをする
ポッカラサーティオーパマンヨスバガワニコヨマハン
このポッカラサーティというバラモン人がいるので
これまたものすごい有名な何人かのバラモン人のうちの一人なんですよ
後で仏教徒になりましたけど
ゴートマソンガ スバカヨス
あるウパワンヤセーナ
ポッカラサーティバラモンはこのように言っております
えーと まあこれポッカラサーティのタイトルですよ
名前はポッカラサーティ
スバガワニカというのは彼のもう一つのタイトルなんですね
かなりタイトル 肩書きある人なんですよ
で まあスバガワニカなんでこのこれ林の主とかいうどんな読み方ですかね
まあとにかくすべてタイトルですよ
彼がこういうことを言ってます
ちょうどそのように ここにあるシャモンバラモンたちはもろもろの超人法
聖なる優れた知見を公言している
彼らのこの言い分は生死の限りだ
なばかりのものだ 空しいものでしかない
偽りのものでしかない
どうして人たるものがもろもろの超人法
聖なる優れた知見を知るとか
見るとか  覚えることができようか
それ悟るだと思いますね
悟る悟ることが  できようかと
このような道理は存在しないのですという
で この若い人もやっぱりポッカラサーティさんの考え方を勉強して知ってますね
知ってるんですけど それは最初から出さなかったんだよ
お釈迦様に対してすごい失礼だから
でもお釈迦様にあんなこと言われちゃう
言われたんだから 自分ももう出してしまったんですね
お釈迦様に対して言ってはいけない言葉
それを言うとお釈迦様もただでは済みません
それがお釈迦様 これが自分に対して侮辱だと
だからバラモン人に対してはアンダヴィニ・パランパラって言っちゃえば
これこそ侮辱なんです
お釈迦様に対しては 今言っている言葉が本当に侮辱ですと
ということ それもう決まりで
だから結局お釈迦様にそれ言われるんですね
この若者は言ってしまうんです
そういう意味なんですけど
200 ページの下から 2行目
エーケーサマナ・ブラフマナ・ウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマ
エーケー あるシャモンバラモンたちがウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマ
マヌッサ・ダンマっていうのは
人間の世界 人間の次元
人間に関わるものということで
ウッタリ 乗り越えて だから人間の知識範囲を乗り越えてということです
アラ・マリア 聖なる境地
アリアっていうのは聖なる
聖なる境地だと言える境地
ニャーナ・ダッサーナは知恵のこと
で こちらで知恵のことを言ってます
で 知恵があります しかし
この知恵は人間の能力範囲は全部飛ばしちゃって
すごく乗り越えている
超越している 人間の知識範囲を超越して乗り越えている
それから聖なる世界だと言うにふさわしい知恵
そういう特別な知恵をパティジャーナ
持ってるんだと だから知恵があるんだよと
シャモンバラモンには
その知恵が一般人にはまるっきりないんだと
一般人のどころか人間にはないんだよと
人間の知恵範囲を乗り越えて破ってますよと
それから聖なる世界 聖者の世界
いわゆるインド教で言えばブラフマンの世界
神の世界にもう入ってるんだよというふうなことなんですね
そんなことを言ってますよ
シャモンバラモンたちが
テーサン・イダン・バーシタカン・ハッサカン・ゲ
笑っちゃいますよと そんなことで笑っちゃいますよと
ナーマ・カンジェーワ・ターダ
ぐちゃぐちゃ言ってるだけでしょうと
口だけで ナーだけですよと
スッッタ・カンジェーワ・サンパジェッ
ただ空っぽの言葉だよと
トゥッチャ・カンジェーワ・サンパジェッ
虚しい言葉だよと というのは
カタング・ナーマ・マヌッサ・ブート
人間でいながら 人間の次元破るって
何言ってるんですかと
矛盾ではないかと 人間でいながら
人間の次元破りますよと
だから私 いう例えありますね
魚でいながら陸上を歩くと
これなりた-- 笑っちゃいますよ
魚でいながらも無理なんですね
歩くということは だからそこ
ロジック錯乱です この人も使ってるのは
人間でありながら人間を乗り越えているんだよっていうのは
あんたちょっとおかしいんじゃないのと
人間にいる限りは人間だよと
人間知ってるものは たとえすごいこと知ってたっても
それは人間の範囲で知られるものだよと
ということをこのバラモンは言ってますね
ウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマ・アラマリエ・ニャーナ・ダッサナ・ヴィセーサン
だから 人間でいながら人間を超えてる
セーナルチーエを ニャッサティワ・ダッキーッスティ
経験するということは
サッチィ・ワ・カリッサティ
悟るということは ネータンターナ・ウッチャティ
ありえない 不可能であると
それプッカラサーティさんの
あの思考学説というかね
論争・論説ですね で プッカラサーティもものすごい有名な
もうまあ 何人かインドにいたんだからね
すごいすごいバラモンたちが
そんなたくさんいたわけじゃないんです
まあせいぜい十人そこそこぐらいで
名前を知れられてる人で
その一人プッカラサーティです
だからプッカラサーティの論理をね
論説をね 人間にいながら人間が乗り越えるっていうのは笑っちゃいますよと
人間でいながら知ることは全部人間が知ることではないかと
だから嘘言ってるんだと
空っぽななんか妄想を言ってるんだと
錯覚だと それは ということで
まあ超越した智慧 悟りの境地を切り捨てたり
否定する で 本当悟り否定するってことではないんだけど
このウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマという言葉
お釈迦様はかなりそこにはまあこだわってるんですよ
出世間だと 人間ではないんだと
それはお釈迦様の教えをきちんと説得して解明して説明するために
お釈迦様にはどうしても必要だった一つの単語なんですね
だからウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマっていうのは
おそらく仏教以外は使ってないと思います
ウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマ
どうせ一言葉だけ使って使わないんだから
パーリ・ディーガ・ニカーヤで
言葉二つぐらい使わないと
ドーギ・コーティ だからアラマリエ・ニャーナ
セージャニ・フサワシー・チーエ
セーナルチーエ その後はウッタリ・マヌッサ・ダンマ
マヌッサ・ダンマっていうのは人間の世界という人間に入ることで
ウッタリといえばもう乗り越えていると
だから英訳してみたら
だからスーパーヒューマンという風に訳してあると誤解するんですよ
だからスーパーヒューマン・ノレッジじゃないんです
なぜならばスーパーヒューマンだからスーパーマンなんですよ
で スーパーマンというのはもうスーパーマンのこの漫画やあれが出てくる前からもね
あのもうそれは言葉使えないってことは
いろいろ仏教学は八十年間やってますからね
で 使わない と あまりスーパーマンという言葉も使ってましたけどね
だからアメリカのスーパーマン人気が出る前に
仏教用語でスーパーマンという言葉
あの使ってはいたんですけどね
仏教人気ないだけで 後であのスーパーマンということも使えないんじゃないかな
だからこれはマンでありながらスーパーということだから
やっぱり西洋人の思考は明らかなんですね
あの人間にできんことをやっぱりやりたいことを同じことやるっていう
だからあまり  まあ人間できんことをやってはいるみたいですけど
スーパーマンは で 日本で使ってるウルトラマンというのはね
単なる猿真似で スーパーという言葉を使っちゃうとかっこ悪いんだから
辞書を引いたらウルトラ・ウルトラという言葉がありますから
これをウルトラマンにしてる
どちらにしたって意味は同じですけどね
ですから 別そうなことはとにかく使わなくちゃいけないんですね
動詞でEXCEEDという乗り越えるというね
という言葉 まあいろいろ言葉使ってると思いますけどね
まあとにかくこれはまあお釈迦様はかなりこだわる言葉なんです
仏教の智慧に対しては
ウッタリマヌスダンマの智慧だと
人間にはない智慧だと
人間にはもうもう起これない智慧だと
と言いながら人間にさせてるんですね
頑張ってなさいと だからこのポッカラサーリさんが悟りなんかはありえないと言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
そこら辺微妙なんです
そう言ったら もう他の宗教家たちにもかなり攻撃されます
悟りなんか修行して瞑想なんかそんなのとんでもないいい加減な話やっていうこと言ってればなくて
ウッタリマヌスダンマに
何やこれと という感じで
それって何か ウッタリマヌスダンマなんて人間でしょうと
だから全くもういい加減な言葉やと
これはもうお釈迦様に対して狙い攻撃なんです
それでお釈迦様は別にそれで怒ることは全然ない
あのこの若者は怒ったんだけどね
それでお釈迦様に対してはっきりと侮辱を返しちゃうんでしょうね
それでお釈迦様は自分も侮辱をしたんだから
別にもうやったことは返してくれるんだから
別にああそうですかということでね
何のこともない しかし
落ち着いて次にまた持っていくんですね
あのダイアログ
キンパナマノ・ブラーフマノ・ポッカラサーティ・オーパマンニョ・スブハガワニゴ・サッベーサンゲーワ・サマナ・ブラーフマナナン・チェータサー・チェート・パリッチャ・パジャーナアティティ
君このポッカラサーティさんが
すべてのシャモンバラモンの心を
心の働きを自分の心で知ってますかと
これ お釈迦様えらい厳密主義
何主義でしたっけ？えらい合理的で具体論でいくんですね
何か言うんだったら しっかりした科学的な根拠があって言いなさいよと
だから あなたの知恵はくだらんそうと言い場合は
あなたの考えはくだらんそうという場合
私はその人の知恵をね
しっかりと把握してないと言えないはずなんですね
だからポッカラサーティさんが
このあらゆるシャモンバラモンたちの心をちゃんと読んでますかと
サカ
ーヤムニ・ゴータマ・プンニカーヤ・ダーシーヤ・ブラーフマノ・ポッカラサーティ・オーパマンニョ・スブハガワニゴ・ナ・チェータソー・チェータサー・チェート・パリッチャ・パジャーナアティ
って面白い この答えはな
で このポッカラサーティさんがね
あらゆるバラモンたち
シャモンバラモンたちの心をしっかりと読み取ってますか？って言ったら
実はお釈迦様 自分の召使いいるんだけど
女の子が あの女の子の心を読めないんだと
召使いの そういうところで
このシャモンバラモンの全てのまた心を知るっていうことはね
あるわけない それにお釈迦様また例え出すんですよ
セッ
ヤタービマーナージャッチャンドープリソーナパッセイエカンカスッカニルーパニナパッセイエニイラカーニルーパカーニルーパニナパッセイエピータカーニルーパル
ーパニナパッセイエローヒタカーニルーパカーニナパッセイエマンジェッタカーニルーパルーパニナパッセイエサマウィサマーニナパッセイエタールカルーパニナパッセイエチャンダマ・スリイエ
ソーエワンワデイヤ タテーバ・セーネン
ジャッチャンドープリソー
生まれつき目が見えない人がナパッセイエ・カンナ・スッカニ・ルーパニ
美しいと美しくないいろんなものは見えません
ナパッセイエ・ニイラカーニ・ルーパニ
青い色のものを見えません
黄色い色のものを見えません
赤色も見えませんし マンジェッタは日本語で何でしたっけ？赤の色も見えませんし
ナパッセイエ・サマウィサマーニ
まあ色 上やサマウィサってのはこのガタガタ状態ですね
あの道路のとかそういうところでね
そういうものも見えませんと
ナパッセイエ・タールカ・ルーパニ
星とかなんとかとかそんなものを見たことはない
ナパッセイエ・チャンダマ・スリイエ
太陽も月も見えません
ソーエワンワデイヤ この人はこんなこと言う
ナッティ・カンナ・スッカニ・ルーパニ
美しい美しくないものっていうのはあるわけない
ナッティ・ニイラカーニ・ルーパニ
青色の何？何言う？青色はありません
赤色はありません 黄色い色ってなんかありませんと
それでどんどん言って
えーとナッティ・サマウィサマ
ナッティ・サマウィサマ
それだけじゃない 美しい美しくない見るものはないだけじゃありません
見る人もいません 赤い色はありません
赤い色を見る人もいません
黄色い色もありません
それで黄色い色を見たという人
そんな人もいるわけじゃないと
そういう風に言うんだよと
そこで最後は えーと ナッティ・チャンダマ・スリヤ
太陽好きなんかはあるわけじゃない
ナッティ・チャッ あるわけもないんだから
ナッティ・チャンダマ・スリヤーナン・ダッサ・アビ
太陽好きなんかは見た人もいませんと
見る人いません アハン・エータンナ・ジャーナイ
なぜならば アハン・エータンナ・ジャーナイ
なぜかって 私は知りませんよ
アハン・エータンナ・パッサム
私に見えませんよ タスマン・ナッティ
だからない 私は知りません
だからない サッマア・ヌコソ・マナーワダ・マナーワ・ワデイヤ
その人がそんなこと言うならば
正しく喋ってますかと
この理屈はよく私に言われますよ
私には理解できません
故にフンネは成り立ちませんと
だから あの確かにお釈迦様でお釈迦様の言葉があってお釈迦様の定義があって
言葉にはね ですから自分に切らない
気に入らないんだから
このフンネやらね それはお釈迦様は別な解釈をしてるはずですよと
いわゆる自分に気に入るように否定してあるでしょっていうことなんで
だからそういう場合は答えられませんよ
もう怒るしかないんだから
この同じ例え思い浮かぶんですよ
私に このまま日本訳を送るってことになるんですね
私はただ答える場合は
その全ての経典にあるお釈迦様のこの論争方法
例えなんかせ 全部何のことなくもう使ってるんだからね
で これもまた楽じゃないですよ
特にテキスト書く場合は
どこかどこですかと引用しますと言ったっても
全てのところから取ってますからね
それも私はよく使うポイント一つなんですよ
だから私に見えんだからありませんというね
ということもちょっと理屈は成り立ちませんと
お釈迦様はこんな理屈でよろしいかと
で ノーヒダンボーゴもそれはよくないんだよと
なぜならば 世の中で赤い色も好きも太陽もあるんだよという風に言ったら
このように青年 このポッカラサーリさんがアンドー・アチャックコ
目がないんだと 目が見えないんです
この場合は目が見えないっていうことが
あのポッカラサーリさんがこの障害者っていう意味じゃないんです
智慧の目がないっていう意味なんです
彼があの超越した人間を超越した智慧っていうものは
知るということはね 経験するということはできませんと
もう目が見えないんだから
それからまあもうもう随分時間になりましたので
一応あの止まったところから続けますので
覚えておいていただければ
私は時間はそこら辺で止まります
それからこの このポッカラサーリさんとバラモンたちの状態をまたお釈迦様は説明してあげようかなと思います
またこのキーワード一つあります
これからもね 仏教ではどうしても使うキーワード
このウッタリマヌシャダンマという言葉やらね
今までいくらか言って
それからも仏教ではもう特にお釈迦様の教えではね
またすごく大事に使う
しかしあまり使ってない
だからみんなに知られてない
気づいてないキーワードがあるんで
そのなかなかこの隠れてるキーワードをいくつかあって
それ発見すると何のことなくブッダの発見できるんですよ
みんなこの注釈書やら伝統的な解釈やらね
ガチャガチャそればっかりやってるんだから
ブッダを理解できないんですよ
だからこの今日のこのようなこのダイアログ対話を見てみると
いかにこの話を持っていくかと
この厳密にいろんな立場をね
ちゃんと明確にしながら喋るお釈迦様が見えるはずなんです
だから質問にそのまんま答えるんじゃなくて
ちゃんと質問の中身を見て
この場合はこれ言ってるんだとかね
例えばバラモン人がイススの法を説いたところで
これは心の成長について語っているんだっていうことを知ってるんですよ
道徳の世界では お釈迦様は心の成長あるべきだと思ってるんですよ
だから君と俺も同じ立場だとそんな無知なことは言わないんですね
では ポイントはわかってるかないかっていうところで
はっきりした科学的な発見があるかないかというところに持っていったりする
皆さんにとっては面白くないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり仏教学校をやったりする場合は大変
すごいと思うところなんですね
ブッダの圧倒ちは  [紙の音]